here's the problem with edibles
they provide a notoriously unpredictable
user experience you ask 10 people to
describe the first time they ingested
weed and I bet you most of them will
tell you they made the classic mistake
the beading too much one company working
hard to solve this problem is an outfit
out of Oakland California called defense
a started by former Apple employees
davon se specializes in fancy cannabis
infused chocolate and they are some of
the most user friendly edibles we have
ever seen
we made the product is accessible
because for the most part people have
had bad experiences with edibles and we
want to change that so really paying
attention to packaging pay attention to
consistency of dosage but also making
something that's delicious two things in
particular caught our eye first thing
was the graphic design it's tasteful and
it's subtle you won't find pot leaves or
any other imagery commonly associated
with weed culture but what you will find
are a clear indication of the bars THC
content simple instructions and sensible
dosing recommendations each bar contains
18 suggested servings of 10 milligrams
of THC each if you're new to cannabis
start with half a serving and look
there's even a helpful diagram
the second thing has to do with the
shape of the chocolate bar segments you
do easily because you know using a
square and do things that other
chocolate bars do all the time where
they just puts a logo on each 18
servings that just didn't seem fun to us
so we looked at you know just other ways
of just adding dimension to the bar day
fonts they decided to go with pyramid
shape segments but it wasn't easy there
are three different shapes in every 18
seconds our and davon say needed all of
them to contain the same concentration
of cannabis so they enlisted the help of
a mathematician to ensure that all three
shapes have the same volume that might
seem like a minor detail but like every
other aspect of this chocolate bars
design it's a premium touch that
actually adds to the experience those
details add up and they're about to
matter a lot more just a few months
California and several other states will
vote on whether to legalize weed for
recreational use which means that a
marketplace that's already flooded with
options is going to become a lot more
crowded it's this kind of attention to
detail that's going to really set
products apart